this video is sponsored by brilliant dog
it was suggested to me on Twitter that
now that I am completely done with the
University I've done my undergraduate my
masters and my PhD I could look back and
ask what kind undifferenced I keep
myself up with at night sometimes where
I think back to specific events or to
just general changes in behavior and how
my life would have been different if I
done those things as it is I'm very
happy with the way that my life has
turned out and I actually wouldn't go
back and change anything even if I could
but if you were to send me back to my
undergrad and you gave me two objectives
to maximize how happy I was during my
undergraduate degree and to maximize the
grades that I got at the end of my
undergraduate degree then I have
identified five things that I would
definitely have done differently
number one end my relationship before I
went to university well we're going in
hard today before I elaborate on this
one I just want to be very clear that
this is specific to my situation I'm not
saying that everybody in a relationship
going to university should separate from
their partner I don't want to be
responsible for like a million
heartbreaks around the world in my case
though it definitely would have given me
a better experience at underground and I
also should be clear this is something
that actually talked about with my
ex-girlfriend we both agree that we
shouldn't have carried the relationship
on to university why was it a bad idea
to continue our relationship to
university well I was studying in Oxford
and she was studying at Cambridge but
that wasn't the problem
and we would see each other every week I
would go and visit her every other week
and she would come and visit me every
other other week that meant that during
the week I was working flat out I was
working 9:00 a.m. till 10:00 p.m. every
day didn't socialize did nothing really
but work even on the weekends I actually
also did work with Herbert that we'll
get to that in a bit
the problem was I was clinging so tight
to the mast of the relationship that I
didn't develop a support network in
Oxford I didn't have a friendship group
and with the time most of my year left
coz I was on a four-year course most
people in three of courses I don't think
there were very many people in my year
that would have called me a friend and
that is a profound regret that I missed
an opportunity to make friends with a
bunch of interesting people and
profound regret that I didn't have a
support network of friends to help me
when things got tough which they
frequently did maintaining my
relationship from school into University
definitely negatively impacted my time
at undergraduate I'm not saying that
everybody would benefit from separating
from their partner because this is
obviously an individual response but in
my case it's probably the single biggest
thing that I would have changed and my
undergrad secondly I would have worked
less now I know that I said that one of
the objectives here was to try and
maximize the grade at the end of my
undergrad which is hopefully you know
what a lot of people watching this video
are probably looking to do I genuinely
believe though that I would have done
better at my degree if I hadn't pushed
so hard if I'd actually taken a step
back from my degree and not worked for
12 or 13 hours a day every day during
the week you will not do well in a
degree if you don't work hard that's
just the fact even the smartest people
at university have to put the time in to
reach their potential and anybody who
claims they don't have to work hard is
just sort of trying to show off there
are however two sub points here one
burnout and two the difference between
working hard and working smart firstly
if you just push and push and push and
put all your time into working like I
did then you will burn out quite
frequently and this happened to me
underground a lot I would just make
myself sick because I was trying too
hard
I was so tunnel vision on I'd got into
Oxford I didn't think I belong there I
was starting from the very bottom of the
ladder in my head I had to work my
absolute hardest nerds to get by but
that resulted in me burning out and
doing worse than if I just taken the the
pace down a little bit and work more
consistently over the course of the year
because sub-point number two there is a
massive difference between working hard
and working smart you will need to put
in a larger number of hours every day in
order to work but it doesn't have to be
an overwhelming number of hours if you
plan your time and you structure your
studies in an appropriate way
this was definitely something I got
better at towards the end in my third
year I developed a system of spaced
repetition where I would have a diary of
covering not just during the revision
period but also during the whole year
when I would cover stuff that had been
covered in lectures and I did by far
best academically my third year partly
because of that technique this is
something that I would make a video
about but frankly thomas frank noted
member of the smart youtuber mafia
already has an entire youtube channel
full of fantastic videos on this topic
so if you're interested in working smart
rather than hard definitely go check him
out
the fact that I persisted in working
myself into the ground and I developed
this mental image of me being in the
very bottom of the academic ladder and I
had to just grind by putting more and
more hours in to get to the top rather
than thinking about how I was doing it
remains one of my biggest life regrets
so if I was to go back to my
undergraduate I would stop worrying so
much about how many hours I was doing
during a day and worrying more about how
I was maximizing the efficiency of the
hours I dedicated to studying this
actually directly leads on to my next
point
committing to extracurriculars Jun my
undergrad I played in a wind band I was
actually the manager of the wind band
for a year when I played saxophone I did
a little bit of rowing I did to terms of
Rome for my college and a little bit of
physic Society and that was kind of it
like I said before I spent almost my
entire time working during the week and
then seeing my girlfriend on the weekend
I just didn't take time to do things
that I actually enjoyed doing compared
that University routine to school where
despite the fact that I was doing debate
hockey discus scouts school officers I
was getting top grades across the boards
because I was happy and I was happy
because I was doing stuff I was
interested in outside of my studies my
mental health improved so much when I
move from Oxford to Exeter obviously
lots of changes happen with that
transition but I think one of the key
things was that I committed to singing
and doing music and doing a lot of it I
dedicated a lot of time alongside a PhD
which is not exactly a minimal time
commitment to an extracurricular that I
love doing if you are in good mental
health you can study better it is as
simple as that if you neglect your
mental health for a long period of time
you will not perform at your best
academically it exactly the same way
that if you neglect your physical health
you're not going to perform at your best
in a race or a weightlifting competition
you have to maintain a certain level of
competence this is something that I
understood without really knowing it at
school and something which I've
rediscovered during my PhD but you
remind a graduate I just threw it out of
the window so if I was to go back I
would set up a time table and fence off
slots for time off and doing
extracurriculars I commit to doing some
music doing some sport spending time and
socializing with friends and ring-fence
time that is for me this actually sounds
an awful lot like advice I was given at
the time and I just ignored taking these
two most recent tips together though I
would absolutely create a schedule and
stick to it I would have a large number
of working hours during the day but also
ring-fence time for doing other things
it genuinely makes me angry to be saying
this now because I heard this advice
letters chose to ignore it at the time
and I can see in retrospect how wrong I
was so if you're a current undergraduate
if you're going to do undergraduate
soon-hee disappoint me the same mistakes
I did tip number four find a study group
I would estimate that I spent about 90%
of my time during my undergraduate on my
own like entirely on my own obviously I
went to lectures and you know you'd seen
the same people all the time we develop
a couple of sort of friends from that
group and maybe sit with them although I
think I did actually quite frequently
set on my own at Oxford you have
tutorials also doing tutorials which are
two or maybe three students with one
academic same students every time so you
sort of get to spend time with them and
then you also have lab work for some of
the year so you're gonna have a lab
partner where you do experiments for a
couple of hours a week but the rest of
the time I was always on my own I was
always in the library working on my own
always been a bit of a lone wolf I
already mentioned that during my
undergraduate I had this mental image of
me being at the bottom of the academic
ladder I came in as the worst student on
my course and I had to work my way to
the top and another part of that mental
image was that I have to climb alone I
had to work out how to do absolutely
everything on my own and derive as much
from basic principles as I possibly
could without any help from others I
think in part that's a laudable attitude
and I think it is important for
physicists to be able to derive pretty
much anything from first principles but
that doesn't mean that you should have
to learn it on your own one of my
favorite TV shows of all time is
community by Dan Harmon
and I think one of the reasons I like it
so much is that it is just so different
from my educational experience I have
never really been part of a study group
the one time that I was in anything
approaching a study group was a
disparate group of students in my fourth
year who revised together and Calvin Dan
and cherry if you're watching this those
hours that we spent revising together in
those rooms are some of my most precious
memories from Oxford though there's some
of my favorite some of the very few
happy memories I have I look back on
revising with a group of people and
chatting and being social and making
studying something which I could enjoy
and I just wish that I'd done it with
from day one rather than waiting as of
the fourth year of my degree those of
you familiar with the Oxbridge system
may be thinking well and there were
other people on your course in your
college you know why weren't you working
with them and in some cases I think that
works right in our College we were just
quite different people we didn't really
gel as a group we didn't get on very
well so it didn't work out it happens
but my failure here was to sort of give
up for him there was a whole university
there are 200 people in my year at least
to begin with before we lost like a
third and first year at least a hundred
people doing my degree in my year that I
could have reached out to that probably
suffering from the same problems of
isolation and loneliness I did attempt
to set up something in my fourth year
again which was called the we suck at
theoretical physics club but it turned
out that a bunch of the people in it
didn't really suck at theoretical
physics and we never met up if I was to
go back to the start of my undergraduate
I would 100% be more social and try and
get to know other people on my course
and get a study group together and get
people to share the load of province
shoes so we can teach each other and
revise together it would have made me
feel like I wasn't so completely alone
and so completely crushed by the
academic pressure I'm not saying that I
would go back and try and make my
university experience like the study
group in community and know a shortcut
the Turkish district just having people
to share the load with would have been a
massive help for my mental health then
lastly tip number five using external
resources when I was studying a given
module in my undergraduate of course I
would use the lecture notes I would go
through the problem sheets which were
set by the tutors I would refer to
cause textbook or textbooks if there was
more than one but that was pretty much
it now the funny thing is I did best in
my third year when I actually expanded
this a little bit as well as looking
through my courses notes I'm looking
through the course textbooks I would
actually take notes from textbooks that
were a little further afield that
weren't recommended but that were in the
college library or taking notes from
online resources I did the best in that
year for just some reason I can't quite
put my finger on when you're learning
and creating your own set of notes your
learning is greater than the sum of its
parts the more components you add to it
the more perspectives that you can throw
on a particular object the better you
will understand that object there are
hundreds of physics degrees going on
around the world and some of them have
great resources that are available
online but beyond that there's also
MOOCs there are also course textbooks
that your lecturers might not be
recommending there are so many resources
that you can use to supplement your
learning and I just I didn't do enough
of that and when I did do it I did much
better so if I was to redo my undergrad
from the beginning from the very first
day I would start finding resources from
other universities reading other courses
notes and whilst you know bear in mind
what I said before about not just
working after after it's trying to work
smart it's trying to work in a way that
uses all the resources your disposal to
maximize your grade at the end
perhaps I was victims of this idea that
no I should be smart enough to
understand whatever is put in front of
me I should be able to work this out you
don't have to make life hard for
yourself the degree is hard enough on
its own use the resources that are
available to you from outside of your
course now if I were to redo my physics
degree starting today then one of the
educational resources that I've been
using myself recently would port over
perfectly into that and that's brilliant
dorg I've been using brilliant recently
to teach myself some machine learning
which is featuring in a project is going
to be coming out on this channel in a
couple of weeks brilliant is an
educational website focusing on maths
and science that emphasizes learning
through doing and learning through
solving problems specifically learning
through getting problems
wrong in this video I've talked about
some of the deficiencies in my
self-image my mental image when it came
to University and one of those problems
was that I thought that failure was
always bad
brilliant makes it very clear that if
you get a problem wrong it's not a
reflection on you it's an opportunity to
learn and it's actually fine but getting
stuff wrong is part of the learning
process the courses themselves are
brilliantly written super clear break
things down into bite-sized chunks and
test you and let make you learn through
solving problems on the go and then as
well as the courses there are daily
problems uploaded to brilliant to keep
you sharp across a range of subjects I
honestly think that brilliant is one of
the most impressive educational
resources across the entire internet and
I've been using it a lot recently if
you'd like to do the same then go to
brilliant dork forward slash at Simon
Clark and the first 200 people to do so
will get 20% off their premium annual
subscription thank you for watching this
video this one has been quite cathartic
to film and I hope that my ramblings and
reflections have been at least vaguely
instructive and useful to some of you if
you would have done things differently
in your undergraduate than do pop your
recommendations in the comment section
below I'm going to be really addressed
to read these of course thank you for
watching the video pop in to like if you
enjoyed it subscribe if you haven't
already and I'll see you in the next one